[Music]
[Music]
right
i'm going to do a quick burger challenge
it's a 10 minute burger challenge
because we're here in
the middle of this incredible park and i
have a wonderful little hippo friend
down there fingers crossed he'll stay in
there
if he stays in there i can get this
thing done so it is a burger cooked on
that by
but i basically in south africa is a
barbecue
okay now i've got a sort of
60 20 20 uh mix
60 chuck 20 rib
and 20 fat so it's quite a lot of fat
into this burger
we're gonna make it a little bit more
local okay now this is a local bryce
spice almost like
uh you're equivalent to a garam masala
now i want to cook this quick okay the
secret when you're up against it
time-wise
is flatten the burger flatten it down
you'll see as it hits the grill
it's going to literally sizzle up and
almost sort of
get back into that nice
tight shape i'm going to put a little
bit butter on there okay
touch of butter just put the back and
there's a lot of fat in the burger but
i want to caramelize that butter okay
now
this is almost going to be like a zulu
burger because i'm going to finish it
with a pele pele
i'll explain that in a minute so burgers
beefy seasoned don't forget to season
the burgers around the side as well
okay it's the one part of the meat that
no one seasons
around the sides roll it in that
seasoning get them nice and flat
and then onto the grill now
but i here we go in
and on good and get those buns toasted
as well at the same time
here we go so get these toasted
toasting the buns are super important
because that's going to give me a lot
more
sort of stability on that burger so we
go to slice it and start breaking down
also when you toast them they absorb so
much more of the juice better and the
bread doesn't go
soggy really important man this is hot
you can see the hip over there slightly
agitated this morning we're sort of
invading his space
tasting my buns and that's going to give
it a really nice sort of crispy texture
beautiful
doesn't look that hot but trust me that
is so hot
now start to lay that up now from there
i'm going to grill
my onions again a little bit of butter
into the onions that'll help caramelize
them beautifully
straight on a really nice hot part the
grill
and now you'll start to see the
uniqueness of that but i
okay so it's like a beautifully uh super
hot
barbecue and i've got a really nice uh
cherry wood underneath those charcoals
from there
take a little bit of garlic okay
i just want to sort of literally get the
garlic
on to the bbq as well i want to roast
that garlic
and go over the burger as well at the
same time this is the most amazing
locally made halloumi okay so it's a
sort of a nice
firm salty cheese now i wouldn't
traditionally serve it
with a burger but the textures are
amazing i'm gonna grill that halloumi
there now flip
onions beautifully charred
there's caramelized onions and the
garlic
every time i've always come to south
africa especially on some of those ultra
marathons we've done
every township has a badai going and
it is an amazing way of cooking because
everything gets done
so easily but the flavor is incredible
cover the whole of that halloumi and it
caramelizes beautifully
it's the only way i really enjoy eating
that kind of cheese because it's quite
squeaky so
caramelizing on the vani gives it that
really nice flavor
now turn that burger beautiful
up beautiful charm those onions
and garlic i'll show you in a minute
now pelipelli this is like the sort of
local spice two-thirds chili caramelized
onions
a touch of garlic and bound together a
little bit of olive oil now
look and place that on top of the burger
so it starts to cook on there as well
now and that flavour
trust me beautiful
again on now when you come to build
these burgers okay think about what
you're doing and the textures
on the base here i get my lettuce okay
and be quite firm with that lettuce
and sort of almost spread the lettuce on
the shape
of the base okay look down
give that a little seasoning there after
that
i got my tomato again a little season in
there
from there just a nice
smidging of my pele pele and that's
going to act like that wonderful sort of
enhancer that will lift
the flavor on that burger
now what i'm gonna do with the garlic
the garlic's now
sort of toasted and i'm just gonna
sit that garlic on top of the halloumi
and sort of brush it
it's got a nice roasted garlic flavor
garlic roast now
from there the most exciting part and
that's assembling the burgers
i've got my cheese it's going to go on
top of the pate
when you taste that now halloumi oh my
god
so tasty now we start the layering
burger goes on
beautiful look at that
and that pele pele gives that incredible
heat grilled halloumi on top
and then my onions
hippos rested beautiful
i'm not a massive fan of raw onions on a
burger
so well beautifully caramelized
cooked onions way better and then
from there just
a little touch of a pele pellet inside
the onion
and then look from there lettuce on the
top
lettuce on the bottom and then bang
look at that that is what i call
a beautiful zulu inspired
burger lightly press it down we can
because we've toasted those buns
and then look
look at that beautiful
and look at that that is a beautiful
zulu burger
bon appetit let me know in the comments
what you think of that amazing dish and
if you missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or
on the nat geo app